hey Kipping him tickets for the live
show are flying off the shelf you ain't
lying gang we just dropped a bunch of
new cities stand up comedy plus we
played a little ayg with the crowd it's
a good good time yeah gang we're coming
to Phoenix Denver Salt Lake City Los
Angeles San Diego Washington D.C
Pittsburgh Buffalo Toronto Pontiac
Michigan then we're going to Chicago
Illinois we're going to Minneapolis
we're going to Madison Milwaukee
Sacramento San Francisco San Jose and
then the boys are coming back to Philly
the chickens are coming home to Rose
Philadelphia Pennsylvania in December
get those tickets we love yous welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah so a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find it at the group to
be classy yeah aren't they just a big
old piece of trash I'm your host Dave
trolley coming at you on a sweltering
day we're out back here at hoodies in
the new edition she's upstairs she's got
her feet propped up on a window unit
okay trying to keep the merchandise cool
you know what I mean my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he's
the prince of the pan pizza he's the
king of the calzone give it up for the
flatbread freak KJ Kevin James Ryan
everybody Kid Likes a zombie man you've
been writing dude you're coming and
swinging on this one what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
iTunes full video of album YouTube as
you know those numbers are real [__]
cooking baby and then obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
check it the [__] out it's a party over
there baby yes sir and having a nice
quick shout out to the magic man number
17 on his jersey about nine and a half
in the shorts lady give it up for T-Bone
Toby McMullen everybody what up boys hey
pal what's up man I'm excited we got the
boss of all bosses
look almost a mock turtleneck Rock in
there too looks like looking like Sammy
the bull that's a that's a full
turtleneck on a regular man
gang the long hair ain't lying we
couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guests back with this again today of
course he is the co-host of two bears
one cave the co-host of your mom house
your mom's house he is the owner
operator of ymh studios and he has a
brand new special out on Netflix right
now currently sitting at number one
entitled Sledgehammer give it up for Tom
segor everybody thank you thank you man
yeah it's an intro uh it's my favorite
podcast
that's it that's all we needed from yeah
get him out of here super happy to be
back thanks for having me thank you for
coming in congratulations man thank you
thank you very much [__] number one
look at it it's very exciting it is
exciting and you got the song too you
got the Peter Gabriel song up front I
had to write a check yeah that's why I
was asking yeah well that's the thing is
like all right you can use the song mate
he's gonna cost you a couple of bucks
this [__] a car it's a BMW it's uh
the thing is you know I've done other
ones and a lot lot of times when they go
what do you want like to walk out or
walk off to and they give you like stock
stuff that's fine yeah it's just like
but I was just like I was trying to
really make
the special special yeah of course and I
was like you know because you can you
can easily be talked about like you
don't need to spend this money but I was
like yeah but it kind of it does add
like an element of course even at a
couple of percents of like that's it's
that much starts you're like oh [__]
soundtracks make [__] movies right
what are we doing here but I I went way
hard because I not only did that then I
closed I licensed a gang Star song now
you're mine so I wrote I bought two cars
but but I just I I actually like don't
have any regrets about that you know I
like this you didn't have to reach out
to him or anything did you no that's not
better Gabriel oh Peter getting no that
was uh yeah Pete all right come to me
birthday party you can have it you want
a boat
yeah no he um he he said yes yeah of
course yeah yeah awesome yeah I [__]
love it uh we were thinking yeah it's
been a minute since you've been here you
were one of the few people that came up
classy here on the program yeah what is
like the very few people have gone
unscathed yeah yes very few people go on
scape however when we were down there uh
at the studios down there in Austin Yeah
Austin Christine yeah but Christina P
was saying you know maybe that might not
be the case dig a Little Deeper find a
little dirt under the fingernails I
think she I mean I think she's right and
the thing is like I try you know you try
to convey like in these kind of things
you're like I want it to be accurate and
that I didn't come from just like it
wasn't uh I mean look I'm privileged but
I also I you know I very much remember
the ascent sure right so like I I and
sometimes you know when the questions
come you're you're trying to make that
clear but you know then people are like
don't try to [__] minimize but you
know I remember us living in uh like I
want to say trashy places but much more
modest places of course and then you
know as times went on yeah and then my
dad just getting like promoted like so
all that like it wasn't like like that
when I was it wasn't like he was arrived
when I was born
um so I do remember that very clearly I
also wanted to remember that when I
first came on come on
himself we talked about Taekwondo sure I
remember that ymas I told you but I
wanted to say on your show that I did
take it at a strip mall and that it was
with Master Hong Kong
the great yeah uh and he gave me so so
many [__] belts that I shouldn't have
you know I'm a black tip keep them
coming back baby yeah one with snakeskin
that was trashy yeah and we always say
on the show the money doesn't money
doesn't mean it doesn't Define you got
to be able to carry yourself and you
carry yourself very well but we do want
to do yeah let's dig we'll put you back
through the ringer a little bit okay
let's see what we can see what we can
come up with oh before this is a little
bit of a side note before we get started
you're a car guy it's well documented
yeah right yep uh I would like your
advice I recently my cars was stolen so
I'm in the market for a new stolen yeah
boys got me who the Kia boys
they [__] Jack my [__] and we're
hanging out in it okay
um so I'm in the market for a new car
guy like me
what would you recommend guy like me
guess what should I be driving around
town uh Kia
Sorrento yeah I like you I mean look I
know how the patreon's doing so it's
true to roof uh here's the thing are you
do you am I bad with money yes okay I'm
very bad with the money are you excited
like here's the thing there's luxury
guys that want to just become plush
that's nice okay you're not a
performance guy I mean what what about
like uh just a benzo what about oh can
we do yeah like the like a straight Bend
I want an SUV I'm an SUV oh your SUV I
think an SUV big guy you're driving here
in the city yeah you don't want to do
full-size SUV I want a big Escalade
that's is what I want yeah they're
amazing yeah I love those things are
like those things are like spaceships
those suck in LA and that's more space
than here so I I had one there and I was
like every time it's great when you like
pull out of your driveway and then as
soon as you pull up to anything you're
like oh [__] everyone's like what are
you doing like they're mad at you for
driving it they're like we can't park am
I good over there yeah it's uh it's so
they're so big they're huge what so you
got to get like uh oh I got one for you
lay it on me what about like a a Porsche
Macan what that's I don't I my family
would disown me if I I can't I have to
import it from Italy but uh oh Porsche
I'm not a Porsche guy and that's the SUV
yes the SUV it's the small they have a
cayenne and they have a Macan okay
yes dude yes and once you drive when
you're [__] you'll never want to drive
anything else
I was thinking a Grand Cherokee or
something no those are great you're
driving around a Ferrari macchiato
I wouldn't need a Ferrari
do you have a Ferrari no that's not a no
no no I don't I don't I don't have one
are you just not a Ferrari guy I love
Ferraris I just I've never I've never
got one really yeah it's a good idea I
should get one he just pulls out his
face he's on carvana right now they're
[__] amazing have you ever driven one
no what are you talking about I just
told you my Kia got stolen first of all
I think he's sleeping I most look if you
I my belief is if it's not a classic or
a a car that you're like I'm I
definitely want this forever I don't
believe in but I only I only buy the
cars that I'm like this is I want to
keep it forever you want this or it's
like it's a special it's a class yeah so
I mean I own
the ones that you should own and then
and I think if you were getting
something like that I would lease that
okay I would lease that all right last
time you were here speaking of which
that number was
I want to say around five or six yeah
was in the uh Arsenal yeah has that gone
up I've moved a lot of stuff around have
you I've sold a few things okay I have
some things incoming okay [__]
um all right this is yeah I'm building a
garage like off site to whoa yeah the
offside garage it's nice too like a nice
chill place that's very Jaylen yeah it's
like kind of like yeah his you know what
his holds yeah
[Laughter]
it has a staff he's a full staff there
damn it's why are you gonna go something
like that no no no it's much more tame
than that security guard and a pit bull
[__] yeah yeah somebody with some steel
[__] Texan yeah these cowboys he's
looking for [__] kickers and shorts
that's all he wears
um okay it's a few I don't know it's a
few cars but like it's nothing crazy
it's not crazy wild huh man oh there you
go Kippy you got your answer yeah I mean
I'm not buying up you're getting it no
I'm not I was thinking we're being
honest I was thinking range Range Rover
yeah and you think wait hold the [__] on
you think Porsche is outlandish but
you're thinking Range Rover yeah I come
from
yeah a poor if you even so I think
anyone in my family's ever been in a
Porsche if it's uh okay are you gonna do
like Land Rover Defender or straight up
Range Rover Discovery wait a second I
can't sit he got shot down on a Lincoln
League
I'm trying to get it so what are we
doing here what are you talking about
you think I'm gonna sit here you try
anything you tried to get a Lincoln and
they're like get the [__] out of here
get shot down
dude I was so embarrassed they handed me
a Jeep Cherokee like it was an ice cream
how long ago
[Laughter]
it was within the calendar week
I wanted to do this today what's your
credit score it's a 750. I want to say
oh then how'd you get turned down what
do you mean
they wanted to Kia they wanted the Kia
they wanted me to give them that's
currently under construction right now
because they found four Dudes in my Kia
so you go in there for a Lincoln what I
went in for an aviator those are dope it
was just too big my wife's got to drive
that's too big for my wife to drive the
sunglasses on and everything
flight jacket were you feeling yourself
you were like
did you do this did you go like this
when you were like were you like Aviator
like that you guys I was doing the hand
signals to [__] land you guys take
Discover card here he was texting the
group chat going guys I'm at the Lincoln
dealership and then 20 minutes later
tonight yeah dude it was out there it
was an open floor plan I'm the only guy
I'm in there and I'm like [__] I'm
like yeah I'll take this like real not
trying to be cool I was trying to be a
guy I wasn't and man they then hide me
and the hole I don't understand because
my current car payment's like 238
dollars a month it's a [__] it's a
Kia so then they were like yeah no one
goes from that uh they're like we don't
trust you've never made a car payment
they're like you're a drug dealer for
sure yeah for sure and then he started
going what can you get your hands on
today and I'm like
I stormed out of a place once really
yeah yeah yeah this was like it was a
number of years ago but I was with
Christina and she wanted um she wanted a
Volkswagen Bug okay so I go to those fun
the dealership and shows this one let me
go to his office and it was he was just
like he was like yeah so I go so
um what's a couple what are we talking
about were you rich at the time no okay
no but it's like here's the thing like
we're just we look at the car having a
conversation it's not like a very
expensive car at the time yeah yeah it's
like
so I go uh can we look at you know this
other one also I wanted to see this
these and he goes would you like this
one and I go yeah like I just wanted to
compare see what else you have and he's
like well you know
if you uh it right away he's like if you
can't afford it you know oh it was like
I was like I just looked at her I was
like let's go that stood up and I was
gonna walk out but before I went out I
stopped in the sales manager's office
and I didn't I didn't I just opened the
door I saw him and I go yeah this guy's
a real piece of [__] you [__] pay
this guy and he was like excuse me I I
was like this [__] skill I just went
like on a rant I've done that at a
couple dealerships where like I I
definitely walked out I was like that
was a little too much yeah well you are
that's some real dad [__] right you have
a
bit of a psycho side I mean I I I feel
like everyone has triggers for things
sure mine is definitely if you're disres
like if I'm disrespectful oh that yeah
yeah embarrassed gets me bad I
definitely think violence first sure but
I'm right there with you I mean assuming
you can't afford a VW bug it's a pretty
big insult I wanted to gut this guy on
the floor like I really did I wanted to
disembowel them in front of the other
sales people dude in front of your wife
too it got even worse
uh people are gonna say Mr patreon but I
so I [__] I get them they come back
they're like they wanted it was they
want to be put down a [__] ton of money
it's not happening I'm like I'm like
this I don't even I just came I
literally Google like I just came to buy
a car I need a car I'm probably not the
same salesman and he's like uh all right
he's like listen we got the price down
as low as possible but that eats up all
my commission maybe you just like tipped
me 600 bucks I get the [__] out of here
buddy this is real yeah I swear to God
because you just give me 600 bucks as a
tip she buy it at Starbucks I was like
dude it's saying Craigslist I'm gonna
[__] out of here
all right so Range Rover
seems like foreign
[Laughter]
embarrassing to say the least man cars
man yeah let's get some more
all right after that yes uh let's do a
little digging yeah I have I have a
couple that have been big on the show
since you've been here okay uh that you
know uh let's weigh in a little bit do
you call it uh
or okay dude when you're getting dressed
will you put your pants on then your
socks or your socks then your pants
pants first
underwear then pants underwear pants yes
t-shirt and then socks last but as
you're like leaving the house you would
put your socks socks and then yeah yeah
okay gentlemen all right gentlemen okay
that's I think so I think it's I do
socks underwear you do socks underwear
yeah
I don't know why it's just funny that's
the under dress yeah you're right you're
right it's just I don't know yeah it's
just an odd look dude you're just
pictured a fat guy in the size yeah I
think I'm just picturing unicycle
underwear okay it's a good time
it kills with the neighbors
make sure you answer the door you're
like what
go get the paper [__] uh is it roof
or roof
[Laughter]
anybody's in your family say
refrigerator
ah
give me something out of the
refrigerator
over there in the refrigerator
not if it's jumping out that's a pass no
because like I'm actually like
I think fridge is fridges fridge is
normal refrigerator oh I feel like I've
heard it but I'm trying to like place
the person who says it it's not jumping
out at me
um
what about hamburger my one of my
sisters says I didn't make I'm always
like she says especially oh you know
she's like I'm big especially I'm like
especially yeah and then espresso I'm
espresso yeah but like you can use all
Italians we'll say Sinatra called it
espresso dumb [__]
like a stupid guinea they're dirty
people greasy [__] stupid Pig it's
spelled out on the board dare you give
it to you yes I mean it's es right like
espresso it's espresso yeah I'm
expressing I just saw the uh I mean this
one obviously gets more of a pass here
but a photo from a restaurant in Italy
and they wrote please they wrote on the
board please it's bruschetta oh I just
saw that yeah yeah that made me laugh
yeah the fact that they were like you
sound like that yeah
please it makes everybody mad your wife
is yeah it's bruschetta when it comes
out of Patty Foley yeah I get the
bruschetta yeah of course yeah they're
like not here okay yeah yeah I'll let
them finish I think especially though
I'm always like especially yeah X like
when they're like X specially especially
especially if yeah I have that I say
vodka too you say no D in vodka vodka
vodka okay two vodka tonics
what about
um
is it ground beef or is it hamburger
meat
hahaha
because one you got to go back to school
yeah I mean I I feel like ground beef is
pretty much like what always comes out
sure and then when someone's like what's
that hamburger hamburger meat
yeah yeah yeah all right
um obviously you flew out here uh up
front or we uh solo
uh I I flew out here
up front Okay uh thank you to the people
at Netflix okay shout out to them very
nice and I'll fly out
yeah look at you yeah you know pick it
on the hotel is it just you or you got a
team on there just me really yeah just
me that would I have a great yeah press
person Jamie thank you for coming
um but yeah nobody else yeah flying now
when you are flying up front all right
yeah
um will you take your shoes off no never
I mean I can't say never there's been
flights that are long where I've been
like uncomfortable but it's not like my
go-to move sure okay and I'm not talking
a lie flat I'm talking like you know
you're it's a couple hour flight you're
up front I've had but I I feel like
that's not like my ah I'm gonna it's
always been like there's some discomfort
sure always socked I've never done it
like that's animals yeah no socks I've
seen the [__] guy yeah I've seen the
guy take his shoes and socks off and
then put them on the screen like on so
that he's like like holding a bulkhead
or whatever yeah holding them on this
and then he's watching TV with his bare
feet on the thing and I'm like yo
um I've been flying in Crocs yeah yeah
but would you put them on the bowl I
can't get them up
yeah they're [__] there's some real
animals on planet I saw a guy flying you
follow passenger shaming yeah it's like
it's so I've seen some wild [__] but
what you see on there is crazy I mean
people drying their underwear under on
the vent cutting their toenails I've
seen that in person really a huge rush
dry in their underwear yeah the Lower
East Side Airlines it's [__] crazy
people really on planes will turn into
[__] animals yeah I don't understand
it well you put your seat back if it's
just not a not a not a lay flat yeah
yes and I really do not buy into this
like there's a whole segment of the
populations it's like you shouldn't do
that I don't think you should really
yeah what if it's what if they're
serving the meals will you checks okay
say they serve the meal you finish
relatively quickly will you just drop it
back will you give a peek back to see if
they're done I would do it like politely
but okay I wouldn't wait till they're
done I just try not to like knock
everything over I'm not like you know
I'm Diane so you'd be jamming me up if
you did that really yeah you're right
into my stomach dude I saw them we were
flying out
that would definitely be a little tap on
the shoulder excuse me he pushed this
old guy forward
who didn't know what happened it was
right away he went back and he was you
know he had about 14 Bloody Mary's in
him he was just like no [__]
Champions I did do this one time like I
go boom and I swear I'm not exaggerating
I heard like that and I was like
yeah dude it was an old guy he was like
my name how's that
I was like
I left it back I didn't care Kim how
about that liquid IV shout out to liquid
eye vizzle saved my life when I was sick
a few months ago as you know gang it's
the summertime it's hot as hell out
there looks good screwing around here
you gotta stay hydrated and there's no
better way to do it what a little liquid
IV I don't care what you're doing get it
in the water bottle Shake It Up
best thing you'll ever do yeah liquid IV
has three times the electrolytes than
other leading sports drinks comes in 12
delicious flavors and now they got
sugar-free uh with their zero sugar
hydration solution and no artificial
sweeteners you can keep yourself
hydrated without sugar without the Sugar
Rush and dreaded 3 P.M crash baby I'm a
big fan listen gang I'm no athlete but I
do booze from time to time sure and let
me tell you I pop a liquid IV before I
go to bed and I don't in the morning
time I'm up and at them ready to crack
them you know what I mean feeling good
in front shemachi uh just mix one stick
in with 16 ounces of water hydrate
yourself two times faster than water
alone real people real flavor real
hydrating now sugar-free grab your
liquid IV hydration multiplier
sugar-free and bulk nationwide at Costco
or get 20 off when you go to liquid.com
and use the code garbage to check out
that's 20 off anything you order when
you use promo code garbage at liquid
iv.com do it gang Camp let's talk about
ladder
let me tell you something
procrastinating something I do all the
time I put things off don't do that when
it comes to term life insurance get
yourself straightened out so you don't
leave the family holding the bag and you
end up in a microwave box in the garage
it's gonna be a big microwave
guys I said it one two three I said it a
thousand times ladders a hundred percent
digital no doctors no needles no
paperwork when you apply for three
million in coverage or less all you need
is a phone laptop to apply I used an
iPad no big deal find out if you're
instantly approved and give full refund
if you change your mind in the first 30
days uh with no hidden fees it's no
wonder why they made Forbes best life
insurance list in 2021 game look at that
uh you're not getting any younger uh the
older you get the more life insurance
costs so stop procrastinating take care
of it now now here's a turkey you go to
ladderlife.com garbage today to see if
you're instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r life.com garbage one more
time again get a pen get a pencil ladder
life
l-a-d-d-e-r life.com garbage
ladderlife.com garbage do it gang do it
but you know the the very the first time
there's no exact the first time I met
Joey Diaz was in Columbus Ohio uh I went
with Rogan to do gigs and he was like
Joey's coming in and Joey shows up at
the hotel and we're like what's up he's
like dog
I almost got arrested and we're like
What okay he's on a flight
and it's coming from LA to Columbus
and the guy in front of him
had lean back during Meal Time first
that's crazy and Joey pushed it forward
and so the guy did it again and Joey
pushed it before he was like my meal is
coming on my lap you know and so the guy
the guy doesn't move forward Joey stands
up
and goes over to talk to the guy and
when the guy tries to like move he
pushed him down he goes you don't want
to do that
and he goes when I when we landed
because we landed in at the airport in
Columbus
on the Jet Bridge was Columbus PD and
they were like Jesus and they go he goes
I knew I was in trouble because they
said are you Jose Diaz he only call me
my mother and the cops call me you know
everybody calls me Joey and they were
like what'd you do he goes I just told
him [__] God told him the guy put my
[__]
veal parmesan's gonna be on my lap and
they were like okay and they're just
kind of like anybody can talk themselves
out of trouble it's Joey I'm with Uncle
Joey on that one yeah there's got to be
a slight sense of decorum okay but you
said that you had that you give I give I
look I do I'm not consider for the old
guy with the name the guy that was like
I think I broke but the most of the time
yeah if it's meals I'll do one of these
like okay all right but most the time
it's like we take off it's like first of
all they do this for a reason like they
do it so that you can sure just like you
in front of me you get to do it too like
I don't know I don't feel like I
shouldn't do it like upfront's obviously
different in coach it's you're it's
brutal you're you're just [__]
jamming yeah yeah that's brutal fly back
and forth with Hawaii back there it's
[__] tight that's tight you do that
yeah back and forth from Hawaii coach
coach I don't know why [__] dude I'm
huge the only thing I have going for me
is if there's an empty seat anywhere on
the plane I'm with my girl they'll come
over they come get them they know I mean
yeah she's [__] smooshed up against
me how much is that how much is that uh
round trip uh like five six seven dicey
is it really yeah first class yeah
and then Coach is like eighty four
dollars
dude the first time he flew out there I
got nine layovers yeah the first time I
flew out there it was like taco
Minneapolis back to college and it was
brutal that's brutal ah I was dying yeah
I was dying all right we'll give you
that
um will you bring anything on the plane
with you any food will you like get a
burger Shake Shack no on the plane no I
think
criminals because of the smells man and
then some people these [__]
non-americans they bring the [__] they
made at home and it's like get with the
program you know make a [__] Caesar
salad or something but don't don't bring
this Muk luck [__] that you [__]
make back in the old country on the
flight the whole [__] thing stinks if
you got Tupperware with a whole bronzino
in there yeah I think they should take
away your citizenship if you bring some
stuff
no there's not in that Range Rover just
yet there's some really foul [__] on
planes oh and honestly honestly it all
of it whenever when you get in this
confined space the air is just like
circulating stuff it doesn't matter if
it's a burger if it's a chicken or
anything hot or warm you shouldn't do
some people bring [__] eggs people
from home they bring their hard-boiled
eggs I'm so against hard-boiled eggs in
public it's insane it's I'm so against
on a plane I was sitting at the gate and
um I was I watched somebody go like
right they were just like and then I go
and it was a lady who had her Tupperware
and she was just like scooping [__] out
with her hands you know and I don't even
know what it was but it was stinking up
the entire area this is at the gate you
know
all right he's a gentleman uh I got one
for you this has been a hot button hot
button issue right you're gonna say yeah
you're it's a normal shower right it's
like a bathtub shower head okay how do
you enter that shower dander from the
back or do you get in the under the like
right under the spout we're not talking
about a glass one yeah like a normal tub
shower normally I would get a hotel you
know at a hotel all right I'm trying to
be very accurate here hit me with it so
turn the shower on I would stick hand
right test and then I would step into
the shower into the tub away away and
gradually go walk in walk in enter it
like a gentleman yeah I would enter that
way you go right under the raw dogs
right in this guy stinks
yeah yeah yeah man I get in there also
his the head of his shower is the
toilet's right there so he crams in this
side and he's like my girlfriend yells
at the floors always so once I'm like no
[__] once you know the temperature is
good you're just like in yeah I'm in
baby
I don't want to put her back in there
I'm insulted you asked me this kind of
thing yeah I want to get I want to get
in here and go wet especially if it's
chilly yeah if it's if it's in the
winter time I don't want to be tiptoeing
in there I want to get in there and get
it over with
nothing
this is bullshitting
okay uh ever play acoustic guitar
man big man
have you ever played acoustic guitar at
a party no no now I'm insulted this is
[__] [__] I thought there was a
little bit of respect
zap
we have to follow a series I think I
stepped on one I don't think I've ever
played one
that's great uh do you prefer uh
obviously you're running a tight ship
health-wise do you prefer Domino's or
Pizza Hut at the time when you were
dominoes because I love the thing I love
Domino's thin crust it's like my
favorite I mean even to this day like
obviously there's better made and better
quality stuff but if you just like
floated it if you were like hey do you
want a Domino's pepperoni thing I'd be
like yeah yeah and then like a minute
later like oh there's a there's the top
knot I'd be like no no get the dominoes
it's good yeah so Domino's over Pizza
Hut for me yes all right now we're
starting to make some [__] senses
would you do that a lot would you when
you were on the road right because you
came up you know through the like the
feature of the car yeah on the road
would you do that or would you eat at
the club or were you were you ordering a
lot of food or you do like microwaving
the burritos and [__] you're crushing it
in a hotel room because you were a
bigger dude I look back Pig looking at
you with those pictures I [__] I mean
here's my what you look like me now my
schedule was like I I would get to that
club
we're doing two shows let's say or first
I guess first night's one show I would
um as soon as I got off stage I would
order you know hey do you have can I get
the the mozzarella sticks you're getting
it to go from the club no no I'm eating
it there between you okay all right
mozzarella sticks then I get like maybe
the burger cheeseburger fries
um maybe the second show I'd be like can
I get that uh
Sunday you know and then we would have a
couple drinks and if somebody had weed
you smoke weed and then you're out you
know just bullshitting then you get back
late and then I'll be like oh or before
we go back to the condo can we do a
drive-through hit the drive through then
I would sleep till like noon or one and
my thing is I always wanted always
always always breakfast food right of
course I have to do it so I was like
where can we get and sometimes it's like
some of these towns here like oh they're
done like there's got to be brutal and
then you find a place and I would that I
would that's where I would do the
probably the worst damage yeah because
it would be like damn you know the hash
browns with the eggs on top bacon and
then I'd be like let's get second
breakfast you know like yeah yeah a
bacon egg and cheese Chaser yeah yeah
yeah and it was like that whatever four
days in a row yeah yeah in the hotel
would you ever use the ironing board as
a as a TV tray for as a desk yeah I put
all I put like things that I brought you
know what I mean like here's a he's like
that picture of the family yeah there's
a picture of the family there's a
Bluetooth speaker yeah there's all
there's like [__] there's like a
camera that I never use
one of those things with the balls that
swings back and forth and I would also
use not to iron clothes but to like
leave clothes like I might wear this
later I'll put this short on it pants
hang off of it wallet yeah all that [__]
is like is on the ironing board okay
yeah have you ever put your clothes in
like the the drawers recently recently
what do you think so towels though yeah
and also like you just like it actually
helps me or I don't do it on every trip
but like
I I like being organized more like it's
easier to see you're not just digging
through the back yeah yeah yeah I like
that I'm not sure if we ask you this
what's the what is the luggage situation
what's the luggage situation yeah like
what do you what what brand do you use
what are you rocking around with that's
cool like designer bags that all match
no but I have like to me I've been on
for more than a decade okay here's the
thing this is the real truth of somebody
that's been touring for a long time
you you will not get and they're not a
sponsor you will not get have a better
company to work with in that in that
line than to me because they make yeah
they make cool stuff they make good bags
they give lifetime warranties
I've gone with I've had too many
backpacks rollers full size
I've had [__] go you know wheel pop off
the handle thing you literally walk into
uh they verify that it's like they have
like [__] VIN numbers on them damn
they verify and then they're like
they've gone like take one of these no
[__] they either fix it there or they're
like we'll just give you a bag so like
yes it is expensive like they're shit's
expensive but it's worth it I could not
I could not endorse them more okay yeah
all right to me is the [__] that's
classy but that's not over the top no
you know what I mean I like it though
yeah they're good will you dance at a
wedding
uh yeah a lit but like I'm not like I
want to dance the whole night you know
like you're out there if like Christina
once a day yeah like this I like this
song or if like especially if I'm you
know what pops yeah what is your go-to
drink because obvious you know obviously
everybody knows what bird but you're
you're you're not as big of a drinker
obvious I mean it goes without saying
come on I'm sorry
um all right so I I I did a lot of gin
and tonics like like that's crazy yeah I
like that I like Anejo on Ice you know
like the tequila and yeah okay sure um
I'll do like a nice vodka uh also just
straight up on Ice
um bam and then I like bourbon yeah I
don't like I like Bourbons okay okay
yeah so those are kind of like my
channel
yeah man you like gin and tonics
ah I I you don't see him a lot yeah
they're bigger in Europe yeah sure
um do you like wine
he's he claims to know I love it dude
but no we no we were we went to Indy 500
I was [__] and we went out to dinner
and he's like I'm telling him this he's
like I'm gonna order for the tape right
anyway he's doing him he's [__]
Johnny we all got steaks yeah he's got a
nice bottle of red for us okay A little
body to it there you go no yeah
he ordered the wrong thing he ordered a
bottle of white there was Cabernet in
the name I think it was the Cabernet is
it okay all right it wasn't a cab
solving yawn it was a cab with Sutter
Home what are you talking about that
[__] waiter was a method he
I think we're gonna do another one
actually I think we're gonna do another
one so in spite of them I [__] house
the whole bottle and then ordered a
bottle of red that's what's up man you
showed them
I threw up halfway through the meal of
course still uh wait before we continue
I gotta piss again of course we're
chilling yeah
I know you did I know what you were
doing yeah it was something I never
really recognized for everybody I have I
have a I have a general knowledge yeah
from from working in the service service
industry all right I know that the Pinot
noirs are going to be lighter the
cabernets are going to be heavier yeah
uh I know a nice smell back I know a
nice San Diego a nice Monty I like a
nice sauvignon blanc I know Pinot is
going to be a little sweeter chardonnays
are going to be a little buddier maybe
buddy buttery maybe a little Oaky
depending on where it's from I know you
know all that are you with that well
versed I mean I have a I would say a a
general knowledge of like certain things
that I like and sure wines that pair up
well with a certain sure foods but I'm
definitely not you know well versed or
anything like that I've also you know
sometimes you have wine that you're like
damn that was [__] good and I'll snap
pictures and try to mentally remember
sure just like some of them so that if I
see it again I'll be like oh that was
amazing yeah would you be usually
ordering the wine at the table would you
be handling it I will do it with um
let's say like yeah with a lot of people
and then I've I I'm friends with some
people that are real sharp real sharp
with wines so of course I'm like you
yeah you take over run and Gun yeah okay
all right so you dance a little bit at a
wedding I will a little bit Yeah but
I'm not doing any of the coordinated
like hey you're not doing the Macarena
the Electric Slide no no no no no okay
can you do them
uh I mean Macarena is pretty simple okay
yeah I mean I just I could but I'm I'm
not I'm not really that guy you're not
into it no how would you rate your
dancing can you hang are you gonna are
other people gonna be snickering or
you're gonna hold your own I think I can
hold my own could you do the worm when
you were a kid I got the dance video you
could do the worm no okay
um going back to the cars for a minute
what kind of air freshener you you
banging in those things
you're not throwing a pine tree black
ice nothing Tom who's insulting now yeah
what's on the rear view mirror of your
Bugatti
you play the harmonica
oh Jesus
uh although I love getting a car
detailed just and I've had and then
sometimes I remember that they've asked
before and I always they go you want
something Cherry I always go new cart
because there's a new cars new cars I go
new car smell okay it's the best yeah
okay this is bird dogs baby shout out to
the BDS welcome to the party boys I'll
tell you that right now gang we all know
you love your old pair of shorts but
listen it's time to upgrade a little bit
and there's no better way to do that
with bird dogs you got the best shorts
you'll ever put on they stretch khakis
design with a slim fit through the thigh
through the leg a sculpted look that's
what I need I need a sculpted look I
need Michelangelo sculpting this out and
bird dogs delivers uh-huh uh they're
basically the same as the widely popular
popular Lululemon shorts except they fit
so much better while other sport why
other shorts are made of stiff
restrictive fat I gotta be on the move I
got people after I gotta be able to
stick and move yeah that's why bird dogs
they use the cloud knit fabric high
kicks feels like your balls in her
cumulus cloud if you know what I mean
walking around like a Rockette uh it
looks just like khaki and keeps the
stretch and allows for a ton of movement
and flexibility their Cloud knit is even
anti-stink and sweat wicking so you can
stay cool and dry all day finally a
little anti-stink okay but they sent us
a whole box of stuff I've been walking
around in my little booties shorts my
wife all of a sudden uh go to
birddogs.com garbage use the promo code
garbage at checkout for free Yeti style
tumbler with your order which they also
said I was having a little [__] vodka
tonic in there uh that's birddogs.com
garbage use the code use the promo code
garbage for a free Yeti style tumbler
you won't want to take your bird dogs
off we promise
um if somebody has a booger or bad
breath will you tell them will you let
them know
I'm much more inclined to tell them the
booger
um even though the bad breath is more
bothersome right I've done where's your
line of people like if one of us had it
well there was a friend would you say
something booger I would tell anybody
okay I'd be like hey man you got oh you
got something you know like you get
attention
breath like you you just try to avoid
for like I do a lot of avoidance right
like uh yeah and I'll you know
yeah man you know you start like
covering up turning away
so the the line is that like obviously
someone's super close to you you can
just tell them of course there's like a
step removed from that where you go like
um do you want some gum you know like
you want a mint and then there's like
somebody more removed from that who you
kind of go like I I'll be like this is
when they go I don't want it I go this
is [__] good like go try this I swear
to God they're like it's spearmint I've
had it and I'm like this is a new one
there's a new one I don't think you ever
have that yeah be honest with you sir
um and would you appreciate that if
somebody told you that how would you
handle all those things yeah I
appreciate sure all of them any of those
things I I like somebody telling me that
doesn't look good on you uh you're
something on your face you need to brush
your like all that [__] does not it
doesn't offend me I I wish it was uh
happening more good good that was good
uh do you own binoculars
I actually have two monoculars what the
[__] is that single
so that's ultimate creep level dude yeah
yeah I can look at two different girls
at the same time
yeah well like a revolutionary general
what do you mean this is like I guess
they it's probably used more for like
hunting yes I know I know what you mean
yeah but I was in an outdoor store and
then uh I saw and I was like that looks
cool and they were like would you like
monocular and I was like dude yeah
tape them together yeah I've used them
once okay I think the day that I got
them I used them and then yeah do you
have a telescope
no oh we bought one the [__] I think
I made a post about it I bought one for
my son for my six or seven-year-old okay
um and like I was out there I couldn't
see [__] with it and I kept I was what
the [__] is going on and then I like I
wait at night I'm like oh It's gotta be
dark you know I still can't see anything
but it's like the real cheap yeah yeah
there's I had a crappy one during the
pandemic really that took me full moon
took me [__] three hours the uh so I
was thinking I was looking for like a
star and everyone was like that's
Advanced yeah
yeah find the biggest yeah and then I
was like I can't find that so I'm
probably done with this yeah try broke
this house next door see what's going on
yeah they're fun though do you still
have a DVD collection
not that I mean it's I think it's
probably somewhere in the house but
nothing that I'm aware of yeah like
displaying it no let me check out Dumb
and Dumber or whatever no okay but we
definitely have some somewhere okay fair
enough yeah do you know anybody on a
mural do I know anybody you know anybody
on a mural and personally do you know
anybody that has a mural
well
I mean like I'm just gonna answer this
question not like we have a mural at our
office yeah we saw them painting Chris
painted it no that doesn't count right
right so I'm trying to decide zany's and
now I'm thinking everybody's on the side
of that are you ones yeah national bird
is okay
yeah that's weird like at my parents
place they have like like my dad has a
painting of himself really yeah and I
think there's one yeah there's one on my
mom there too that they that's old
school yeah it's pretty old school yeah
and it's them in like their 60s sure you
know like yeah that's good Frost or
whatever yeah yeah right are you a
family paint that's pretty standard to
the left a little bit okay
that ain't bad do you sanitary I got
sorry I got one done uh like this
neocubist one done of uh I don't even
know what that is of Christina from this
uh guys the Spanish painter yeah oh it's
like a PR that's pretty cool that was a
cool like because I like his stuff his
name was Berlin and I commissioned uh
him to do that that's what we're talking
about yeah that's all right I just
bought a bunch of his stuff really yeah
I bought like
12 of his pain where are you putting
those it's class
um so a bunch of them are going in that
garage oh there's an office and then I
um I've been buying more artwork this
Summer that someone's going to the house
have you yeah you've been buying a
little art a little art yeah look at you
all right but I I love walking into a
home an office a hotel that has like
that has art I just like you know I go
to Art Museums if I'm on the road and I
have oh do you yeah I haven't done it on
this trip but I would have if I didn't
have full days
you ever see that one where you got to
stare at it for a long time and then the
space shuttle appears yeah whatever
you're talking about exactly and you're
like that's a [__] dolphin I can't
see it yeah
damn he's purchasing art uh I assume you
have somebody helping you with that
right like a broker or whatever honestly
like
no you're just handling it all yourself
I've done it all myself I mean I've had
like so I've gone into galleries have
you and bought it like that really the
thing is though they you're a Mark when
you do that the moment you do that they
try to sell you more they follow up with
you sure I mean I had my neighbor had
this Gallery guy that he bought from and
then referred me to him this dude was
like he sends me like all these images
like do you want these and I was like
yeah I like this not that he's like all
right how about these six things for
like you know all the you know like no
and then he goes what if it was like 30
grand less you're like what the [__]
you're just like just [__] just by
being like I'm not sure and then you
know so you that that part feels doing
clearance deals with you Gary yeah okay
I mean I'm not like very well versed or
but I do enjoy it I do like it that's
what I was looking for and that's pretty
good yeah the family having one is real
classy though yeah that's real nice will
you say goodbye to places when you leave
like go buy a house
the boys do that my boys do that so does
mine yeah yeah and like my uh my wife
will will make like she'll be like uh
you know say goodbye and they go bye
there you go yeah yeah they do that like
like it's like say yeah they're they're
how old again
they're now four and seven so not
they're not 47 years old
okay what do you do like okay so say say
we stay at a hotel and we had a nice
time thank you Hotel I guess we're
leaving the room buy hotels or like
we'll be backing out of an Airbnb he's
like buy Airbnb and I just have to act
like that's normal that's adorable yeah
it's very cute damn
super cute are you currently any B in
any beefs with any neighbors
uh no okay okay you ever put a napkin on
your shirt when you're eating talk a
little tuck in I mean I've I can't say
I've never done that it's not a regular
but I've done it I've done it like more
like oh [__] there's a second show right
like that you don't want to like
and you're wearing a light color and
yeah we use a lobster bib if you get
Lobster yeah you will I will yeah okay
because a lot of times the places first
of all they
a lot of times they'll initiate I'm not
gonna stop someone unless for a reason
they're doing this they've seen this a
thousand times yeah I don't usually go
can I get the bib but if if they come
over but sir you're having the chicken
yeah yeah yeah yeah it does kind of feel
nice though it does you look getting a
haircut yeah like you look goofy as [__]
like you see a photo or something but in
the moment you're like yeah make it
tighter yeah we're going in let's have a
good time all right okay uh when was the
last time you're at a Hibachi restaurant
um and what's your overall feeling on
hibachi with slicing and Dyson and the
communal table flipping shrimp in your
face hitting on your girlfriend it's I
mean it's a fun time I haven't done it
in a while I feel like I feel like I
would be
I should say like some something in like
the LA 12 18 months something like that
oh really I think so I mean you know it
could be
two years sure it's it's definitely
happened
um
yeah it's really like when the other
people are you're like I don't want to
[__] eat with this guy that's the
turn off I've had fun with like when
we're done of course that's fun yeah
some you know the guy being
fun yeah you know my one of my most
memorable ones was
my older sister she enlisted in the Navy
at 34 which is the cutoff age Whoa and
she went to The Language Institute in
Monterey California and she signed up
for Mandarin right okay Chinese
and it's intense it's like eight hours a
day Jesus and then after she was in this
program for a while we went to one of
those places The Hibachi places and you
know they'll just they'll hire a Puerto
Rican they don't give a [__] they're
just like yeah you're just not white you
can do it so this guy's [__] chopping
it up and she just looks at him and she
was like me how and right and he was
like
and
this guy he froze right and he thought
maybe she knows does she know where and
she just starts speaking Mandarin this
guy I'm not kidding you he has this
thing and he goes
and then he speaks broken English and he
stops the whole thing there's other
people at the table he's like do you
know
how hard it is to speak Mandarin and and
I'm like I guess so and he could not
believe he couldn't believe that a white
lady was speaking Mandarin to him he had
trouble like moving on really oh yeah
[__] he couldn't slightly he couldn't
hold the egg and he was just like gotta
make the volcano for to save his life it
was a mess he was just like he'd seen a
ghost okay it's pretty sharp pretty can
you whistle with your fingers no can
can't can't do it but your dad no that
was a dad thing that was a dad thing and
I always thought that was [__] badass
I wish or also even the the forceful
like where you're like Jesus how do you
generate that sound three football
fields away that's it it's just
incredible this thing like with yeah I
always I wanted to do it yeah never
could if you've ever washed your shoes
in a washing machine or a dishwasher
uh
no okay um I feel like
I've definitely had a pair that I've
been like [__] you know muddied up and
I'm trying to remember if somebody else
like someone they come out odd they
don't hold they're not dishwasher do you
know someone's done in a dish that's
like a that's a that's like a hack
people do it really do my cleats and do
your hats in there and stuff like really
I've never [__] heard of this ever
yeah yeah no it's a thing they even make
like racks for your hats that you can
put in so it'll like hold the form keep
the Beak from bending and you put it in
there [__] I think if you think if you
don't like wash it with your pots and
pans it's just a you know a high
pressure washer I guess okay yeah yeah
you've never done it it's trashy would
you ever wear a pair of sneakers out of
the store go in and get a pair of
sneakers and wear them out yeah yeah
just what do you do with the old pair
throw them out no I put them in the put
them in the box yeah definitely he's
giving them to the guy to throw out
really
down to the filter baby it goes just
throw these out I'm like he said that's
bad form that's an insane move why
how is that dude they're throwing stuff
out you just you just give something
he's like you take care of this yeah I
give them the box I say my old ones in
there you can throw them out you can't
keep them if you want you can sell them
yeah
they still got some bouncing on this
yeah all right they got a little kick to
them
what's your what's your go-to do you
have a go-to sneaker uh I've been I've
been I've been really rocking Adidas's
lately yeah I guess I'm on right now
yeah I've been rocking Adidas they're
very comfortable yeah I like these and I
like to slide in
I like I like a no fuss yeah I'm not
[__] with the laces
we've been jammed up at TSA yeah yeah
that was one of the main reasons why I
got TSA pre-check I don't take my shoes
off anymore yeah I'm [__] walking
around like I got clogs on because I
can't get my feet in there it's so funny
to be like I want to get sneakers and I
don't want any fuss
because sneaks give you so much fun
yeah yeah a lot very comfy that that um
what's it memory foam or Comfort foam
whatever they got and you you have a
go-to I mean I've uh I tend to be a Nike
man yeah yeah I got into dunks recently
like the high top dunks and stuff their
skateboarding line SBS so comfortable
right I rock those they're just so
comfortable that's one thing I did get
into shoes I'm just like I've been
ordering a lot of [__] it's a phase yeah
like when you start to be able to like
you're like oh I can just cause shoes
and haircuts for me were a thing that I
could never afford really well they
always just got pushed off I was like I
have going out drinking or the bills or
whatever it's like haircuts wait another
week shoes can wait another yes yeah
yeah so now I'm like I want to get a
haircut every week and I'm fine nice
dude I like it look at guys living large
and a Lincoln if they play ball it's
gonna be a rainbow it's Range Rover yeah
yeah what are your cosine terms
huh how do you pronounce uh the product
that Crayola makes
oh
crayon that's right yeah you don't do we
had we had this discussion oh we no no
no no we've had it that people say Crown
I'm a crown man and then it's a crayon
it's Crayola crayon I didn't even that
sounds I was 43 when I found out that
somebody says Crown yeah I was like the
[__] are you talking about is that a
Philly thing I think it's a I think it's
a Mid-Atlantic Dirtbag thing yeah yeah
Crown Crown I'm like I don't uh what are
you talking about I remember my dad
saying I think it's both your crowns get
the crowns and draw yeah he's not the
sharpest
I mean I think it's a both your parents
work and you were home alone for sure
it sounds it literally sounds made up to
me it's like somebody's saying like how
do you say water and you're like we say
whoosh yeah what the [__] are you
talking about like you can't get there
with the letters yeah it doesn't make it
doesn't make sense to me usually if you
say it like that they were broken in
half you were using them you were just
like the rapper was off too yeah
uh any magazines in the bathroom at the
house and you subscribe to anyone does
the household subscribe to any magazine
car magazine I'll say this I love
magazines okay and I was a magazines are
were in every single
um
home and an apartment and bathroom that
I've ever lived in and I did subscribe
for years and years and years I feel
like that only trailed off in the last
maybe five to somewhere in the last
decade it's like it's but I still if I
walk by a magazine stand I'll sometimes
buy six seven magazines
car magazines or whatever I'll buy some
car magazines I might buy like a travel
magazine a news one yeah I'll just I
love magazines yeah but I just I don't
subscribe anymore
and I love having them laying around my
mom my mom is Southern Living and
they're nice to leave through every once
in a while yeah sure architecture stuff
yeah my wife does architecture as digest
yeah A.D you throw them out yeah yeah
he's not gonna read them what are we
talking about here did you ever go where
is that A.D he did she came home
yesterday and actually asked where's the
winner issue yeah yeah I was like I
don't think they delivered the mail's
been [__] up you've been gone in the
bathroom at the house now any uh do you
use an air freshener in there do you
have a little something or would you are
you matching you got black ice in there
what are you doing we got uh
usually like no there's usually nothing
in there
um
you're not a match person that was the
one I want to get to I like I I love it
too but we don't like here's the thing
I'm I'm thinking of like I'm thinking of
the last 15 years it's definitely been
matches and a lot of them in my current
bathroom so the bathroom that I have in
at home
there's a there's like the main the
bathroom you walk into and then the
toilet is in a another room another room
like a classy hotel and then and so like
that's not like set up for anything else
in there gotcha it also is a
it's a
Toto toilet Toto very nice so when you
walk in the lid opens and it says like
hello like give me your Kaka you [__] my
mouth and you [__] in its mouth
and then it has the button so you like
it auto flushes if you move and then it
has the spray built into it so you clean
yourself right away and you feel like an
animal when you're not there you know
because that thing I just sit for like a
whole cycle or two just like and then
when I check with paper it's just wet
paper there's nothing there
all the kaka's gone
it's amazing that's the best this guy
runs a tight ship yeah it's all right
any uh pooka necklaces in your history
no what never I'm sure
I thought that if you're asking me was
there an age where I thought a shark
tooth was cool the answer is absolutely
yes but did I have any poker necklaces
or anything no any Dave Matthews tickets
in your in your past no I've never been
to a Dave show never been a Pearl Jam
Pearl Jam's all right yeah yeah was
there any any questionable jewelry in
the early days some later days too yeah
I had a pandemic purchase that uh is
kind of funny to me it was like this
necklace that was uh it's like like
black
you know I mean like black
um metal yeah like black metal like just
like like a relief pitcher like I have
something that like a cool black guy
would wear and I was like I was like
that looks cool and I was rocking that
[__] for a while and then people were
like that's about yeah that's cool you
know I've got a couple of those and I
was like uh yeah I probably shouldn't
any um any rings at any point thumb ring
never never no this is obvious this is a
wedding a wedding but it's also an aura
ring okay so it like does like heart
rate sleep all that stuff those things
are nice um a lot of watch purchases
sure a lot of watches but I don't
like I don't have anything I go I'll
regret buying that um
the uh yeah I feel like that pandemic
purchase
uh necklace was like the time I bought a
vest and thought it was cool what one
was this that was years ago but I was
like I was like I think I was in high
school high school yeah yeah
and I put it on and then people were
like whoa dude yeah
not like uh not like Marty McFly like
outdoor vest like you mean like uh yeah
but like with a T-shirt and like a like
like yeah like like Ferris Bueller or
something you know but like it was like
a magician like a magician like a tuxedo
best yeah and I had it it was for is
this your card and here's the thing it
was expensive it wasn't cheap I think I
like asked my mom and I was like please
it was terrible it was bad yeah it's
definitely a boat it's a strike uh any
fake Sports covers as a kid for baseball
or whatever is you have like you know
All-Stars or anything like that
or something would your parents spring
for them no no I didn't have any of
those but I know exactly what you're
talking
is there any trophies in your home at
the moment
is there any trophies no no okay
everywhere pins everywhere you go
through a pin phase where you wear pins
I've been given a lot of pins people
give me pins like crazy I think I've
pinned I put like a pin on a jacket or
something
a couple times okay not not like hey man
I gotta get my pins together you know
like check out my pins dude yeah yeah I
had a cool smiley face Dom pin uh
somebody gave me once okay um yeah like
a dominatrix oh okay where it was like
she was holding the the paddle sure I
had it on a jacket I was just like when
was how old were you 42. it's just not
that long ago I thought you had it on
the vest no because they gave me a bunch
of them and so I had a jacket on I put
one on I don't know it wasn't like any
Patches at any point never I was not I
was not patch guy well you are a best
guy so I don't know where the lines are
that was a one-off I regret telling you
what about a lifeguard hoodie you ever
wear one of those
red ones that just say lifeguard come on
now we got it so ridiculous
I don't think I had a life damn it's so
good though
um when you're putting on a shirt when
do you put deodorant on before the shirt
or after the show this is an excellent
question thanks for coming to the show
Tom
so what I've found that's crazy that
would take this long to figure out is
that a lot of times you know I'm I think
I'm right there with okay so I've I've
you leave well you dry off getting
dressed all right pants are on not the
socks yet and they're not animals and
you go deodorant but you're because
you're exposed sure deodorant and then a
lot of times when the T-shirt comes on
you get tea you get deodorant on your
T-shirt and you're like [__] especially
a black T-shirt I mean so the the the
way to prevent that is to put the shirt
on but then you gotta like you gotta
make the room stop that you don't get
deodorant all over the inside so yeah
I've here's the thing it's I'm 44 and
I'm still challenged by this like I
still haven't cracked the code yeah I'm
still like oh there's [__] deodorant
everywhere yes yeah okay and if you put
deodorant on here's another thing if you
put deodorant on
and your shirt's off and then you go oh
I'm just gonna put my shoes on first
like you just do that your armpit will
like then it gets everywhere it gets
everywhere yeah yeah okay fully you're
not you're not with us
when does it go on ah right before the
socks right before the socks yeah wait
shirt's on no never shirt on it goes
underwear socks deodorant hit it with
the deodorant
no
he's a Mitchell man my divorce cop I
feel like I thought you'd definitely be
a spray guy I was as a kid that [__]
stinks that was like bear spray dude
that would get you yeah no I'm gonna I'm
a no antiperspirant deodorant guy okay
just deodorant just deodorant okay yeah
what are you banging with uh I have Old
Spice and Dove I'm a dove man too yeah
Dove's nice it's like the the powder not
the powder but it's like the white yeah
and oh my God people will be like what's
your cologne it's like that's great yeah
stop me like what are you wearing I'm
wearing deodorant I'm like oh jeez
nice huh okay all right man huh have you
ever owned a switchblade or a butterfly
knife yes
um
well
I definitely it was a butterfly knife
yeah did you try to tricks with it of
course slice yourself I've cut myself
I've got myself okay that's one of it do
you uh clip your nails or do you bite
them
this is a
really emotional question for me good so
I started biting my nails my fingernails
and cuticles when I was probably six
cuticles yeah you're already on cuticles
at six times yeah
and then I
would you be that kid yeah
so like you'd be able to see like that
the big no well it was like there you'd
see my mom didn't let those kids sleep
over no it was it was bad here's the
thing you know what um when I stopped
really biting my is is this is the only
thing that ever worked I did things like
I did hypnosis really I did um they sell
this
um you know nail polish yeah that tastes
real that tastes best so we have a
reminder
I was like well I mean not just kid like
20s 30s like no kidding so then when I
was uh when I got when I broke my body
uh playing basketball this arm was
broken and I couldn't pull my hand in my
mouth so this hand grew in because it
was like weeks months of like not being
able to move and then I had nerve damage
so I couldn't like manipulate them
so then I had like a fully grown out
left hand
of like and then this one was like all
mangled and then I was just like that's
you can't go you can't do that uh-huh so
it was like being forced to visit and
you also could visibly see it so this
was like and then and you go like this
is actually nice and it feels good and
I'm not like hiding them
um I say this as I have a Band-Aid on
this side but but like you could see
that like I have like grown they're nice
yeah and like uh so you're clipping them
now yeah I clipped them and it's it's
like strange to me because you know what
happens you go
I'm so used to not having nails and
biting and chewing them that I go oh
should I let them if I clip them then
they'll be gone like I don't don't you
you know I mean like it's straight it's
strange to me because I'm so used to not
having nails that I feel like if I clip
them it's like akin to biting them you
know yeah because they're like then you
lose yeah here's the thing though you
had it you were doing it but then you
recognized it and you rectified it
that's pretty classy well thanks it was
bam it was only because my arm broke
yeah
but it does I'll tell you this it feels
so much better to like to not be like I
would look down and be like oh I would
hide my hands will you do a manicure 100
you will yeah I mean I I don't regularly
get them but if I'm in a place that like
that does and I can I can make that
happen I've done it it feels amazing you
do a petty get a petty get your feet
done I haven't and I only heard that
it's
the best they're awesome yeah yeah so
you're clipping your own toenails yeah
okay yeah
all right it's pretty classy man were
you ever are you currently a fan of the
TV show Deadliest Catch
I've seen it I wasn't like a did it
never caught you it doesn't really catch
me now okay any gardening going on at
the house gardening gardening that I'm
involved in no but there is some
well there's gardening done but I don't
do it it's not a guy I'm talking no no I
know that but I'm talking are you guys
growing any vegetables or anything like
that yeah yeah you got a guy growing the
vegetables no no like uh there's the
gardening people do like the the big
stuff like flowers and Landscapes the
kids and my wife have planted stuff okay
yeah tomatoes and all this stuff yeah so
you're not so it's not just the
landscaper coming in and cutting the
grass you got some things being done
some things being brought in yeah yeah
that's a whole don't look at me like
that that's a whole other level of
landscaping no it's not having a guy cut
the grass is one thing if you're getting
the mulch done and bring it in you don't
think he's got a [__] red maple trees
and all that kind of stuff you're
rotating that stuff around
uh I don't know I really don't know do
you have any bushes that are like
trimmed to look like you
know of course the one is it says
Sledgehammer it's like the whole thing
yeah it's a problem yeah like 50 Grand
it's a write-off Whoa man all right I
mean good I got a couple I think here uh
the last 365 days have you taken a
shower and then put the same pair of
underwear back on you had before the
shower
I don't think so man okay where's this
get me me either
I was lying about that deodorant thing
where's the towel go when you're done
when you're done in the shower at the
house you're done you're done shower
boom where are you putting the towel
when you're done with it
on a rack somewhere like you know behind
the bathroom door
well there's there's multiple Hooks and
racks okay find one and leave it there
what's the usage time how many how many
uh showers will you get out of one towel
um you don't even know the uh just
because there's an abundance of towels
yeah there's like a goddamn [__] man
yeah there's a lot of times Equinox in
there I know yeah there's there's a lot
of towels jeez yeah
um I assume they're doing all right I
assume they're all matching right
they're all the same power yes
not like a Mickey Mouse one thrown in
there somewhere like a worn out one I
always loved that one uh all the
silverware matches in the drawers in the
kitchen right yeah I think well
there might be like two sets or
something okay you know yeah okay you
have a china cabinet like with like like
dinner like uh formal dinnerware so I
think there's a there is a
there's a version of that there's like a
a cabinet that is like not exposed I
think it's hidden that has like Formal
Wear really yeah very nice that's great
[__] bulletproof
um all right I want to pick one of the
three TGI Fridays Applebee's or Olive
Garden
Applebee's
solid choice solid Choice any baking
soda in the fridge at the house no not
currently but I've had I mean I've had
that before for sure you keep batteries
in the in the fridge no but I've also
done that before uh-huh what I'm
answering these as like shortly right
now but I have done that before
you ever call into DJ Delilah
what no
you know DJ that was a deep cut he
pulled the people now I've never heard
of it DJ Delilah you know she does like
the breakup on the radio is that like
psychic kind of stuff
it's not as clear oh okay
um yeah she does she does like like an
overnight show where you can call in hey
this guy broke my heart or I want to
send the song out the no that's amazing
Drew
okay I mean I [__] yeah I mean
you know how to operate a forklift
[Laughter]
you know it's crazy if you have
Christina here yeah what do you mean you
got it you gotta have her you gotta ask
her that
is her dad
had a forklift operation he built and
repaired and uh restored and sold Fork
like she knows so much about it but she
took her driving test on it exactly like
she's gonna hit so many high marks on
this I can't wait she really knows
she'll look why she says
that the zx24 yeah I'm like huh damn all
right you know how you get a lot you get
things now if you get like pretzels or
something like that now they have the
resealable bags will you tear that or
cut that
it comes with the ease of opening it
some of them are very frustrating yeah
I get I get very upset I could just see
you struggling and then I cut I cut it
menacingly and I try to teach it a
lesson but like when it's there easily
it's it's nice very nice yes damn now if
you get takeout will you if you get food
delivered or whatever to the house will
you plate the food or eat it out of the
container it's in again this is a
question I mean I have done both sure
like I feel a lot better if it's like
sometimes you get like a nice meal
delivered sure it's nice to remove it
and put it on the plate especially if
you're gonna have like a knife involved
yes right but of course like
you just you know whatever the sandwich
I'm like yeah I just want to like wolf
that yeah okay do you like ladyfingers
the cookie lady fingers is that like a
butter that's like a butter cookie yeah
it's like what would they make tiramisu
out of
I would say yes
how many bathing suits do you have more
than one yes yes
I got what do you wear jeans like a
Mexican
sometimes if the water's cold yeah uh
when you guys are done with the sponge
at the sink will you put it underneath
the sink or throw it out you have a
little collection of old sponges under
your sink that's a constant like
rotating thing you're collecting them
patties my mom's got like four or five
that are used so once it's done being
used for the dishes then it's used to
scrub something oh I got it rock down to
the washing room where the laundry is
and I don't know what she does with it
man yeah I mean I look the
I'll be honest I don't do a lot of sync
work uh not doing wet work anymore but I
I I've seen like we've had them I've
seen I've seen piles by the sink I have
seen them below I went the other day to
use the grill and um that's what I
always do was like like trying to find
and I found some like you know the metal
yeah steel wool yeah the steel wool so I
cleaned the grill with that
um and then it's like it's a disaster
you have to toss that
um but I also am a big fan of top like
something's I run its course
really yeah what if it's like a real
expensive one like a Scrub Daddy or
something like that then it stays but
like you Christina by the way is like a
real like
lunatic about uh she tosses food so fast
really that's classy yeah but hers is
because she has a fear of getting food
poisoning like a real real fear so I'm
kind of with it on that I'll be like
where's the [__] where's lunch yeah
where's the chicken and she's like I
toss it like you tossed it made it last
night it's [__] good she's like yeah
we don't roll the dice with that the
Foley that goes that goes right away
right away yeah all right uh [__] I mean
he's got us again [__] dead that
right to this guy
I got nothing I mean there was keep the
box of things if after you buy something
will you keep the box for a while I got
I got better at it so now I dispose but
I was bad for a while I was I was a I
was basically I was it was a Christina
thing where she was like so I put all
the flashes they don't need full TV box
here yeah and I and I so now I get it I
but I'm always feel like I don't have
the box
there's something in there that I'm
gonna need it's like this so I just take
everything out do I have the cables and
now I dispose of
um but I was a bad box collector for a
long time
what about an egg with two yolks will
you eat it
give me something will you yeah I paid
for this there you go that and the vest
I think we got them yeah I think you got
it God damn it pretty he's classy Tom
Segura yeah what's that yes class
that's that's he's got a Lincoln on his
hand yeah
he just hands it to you okay give him
this God damn it Tom Segura second time
in a row all class number one
it is unbelievable thank you brother
it's uh look what you guys have built is
awesome I'm a huge huge fan thank you I
hope you just [__] ride this wave you
guys have built it's a it's such a fun
show to watch to be on I'm really happy
for you guys success so I hope you just
keep thank you very much
congratulations thank you so much for
coming in anything else you want to
folks out there to know other than check
out Sledgehammer sledgehammer and uh go
to tomskirt.com for uh upcoming shows
that's it yeah yeah KP what do you got
for uh re garbage.com all of our live
shows they're selling out we're adding
some dates get the tickets it's a good
time game we love you we're gonna get
you one of these days we're gonna get
I'll come back anytime gang we love you
we'll see you next week